can I explain myself yeah go ahead
because they don't know they only know
goodlooking Bobby with the good rock and
roll hair wow and the missing tooth they
only know that guy they only know
goodlooking rock and roll Bobby hot hot
rock and roll chick that's all they know
you know what I mean missing tooth
cat cat hair cat hair and beanie like
they only know that one yeah yeah onesie
shirt onesie shirt that's all they know
I know Bobby hawaian shirt Haan shirt
and your act was and and used to do my
hair he used to take a shirt not a small
comb those Ace Combs the black Combs and
then he'd make his hair poopy for no
reason your hair and you know my he
would make his hair this big and when
and now I'm not can I finish let me
explain why I thought you had Down
syndrome go ahead God let me explain
like I'm not just trying to be funny you
we all thought you really hurting my
feelings but go ahead okay no really
Bobby can I explain okay so we go to La
Hoya and the guy the MC goes oh my God
this kid killing it out here you know
what I mean he's we got to hurry up cuz
his bus is
up and then they go Bobby Lee everybody
Crowd Goes Crazy he's a local favorite
right and then he does his thing where
his eyes are kind of like cuz he was
kind of doing a stoner thing then he had
this big like hair and then he'd move
his head and it took him forever to get
to the microphone and I thought oh he's
he's special yeah yeah but you know what
that's called
mugging yeah I was [__] mugging for
the crowd you [__] piece of [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I would go up
there right I would mess up my hair and
you know what my opening line was what
I'm not really Asian I just woke up two
minute Applause break crushed bro
standing oh standing oh I can see no I'm
not even joking a [__] Applause break
I stood I know but then we went to your
Vegas show that you set up and there was
like 10 people there and that was half
your family and it was terrible but let
me explain why why um because no because
no glad and I'm glad you're telling this
story I drove all the way over there
because there's a lot of comics and if
you want to get personal and real on
your show yeah there's a lot of comics
that come up to us and ask us how how do
you get to that that place that you're
at well this is what I did I rented out
that theater because no one was in Vegas
they didn't have open mics like you did
like if you want to go play catch a
rising star you had to be a headliner
from La you had to play 7 days a week so
I went to uh UNLV and uh and my cousin
Mona was kind of like a alumni there she
was a cheerleader for the Running Rebels
back you know what I mean so she goes I
know the the Filipino Association
they'll rent out that that room for you
for free and I tried and I told them I
got these Asian Com comics and it would
be great to like show support for Asian
Comics that are coming up the show will
be free just let us you rent it out for
us and the show will be free to the
students and they go no they said no did
you tell anybody about the show though
no you're not listening to the story
like I get it you want to go to the
punch line and that's why you're still
here look there's you have to set it up
slowly set it up slowly you're you're
right
story I understand bro but there's an
art for in the storytelling you got to
really give I'll give there's
ingredients in go ahead just go for the
turkey butthole you got to put stuffing
in it do the Slow Burn the Slow Burn so
uh I they said no and it was the
Filipino Studio Student Association that
said no to me and I was like really you
better get a big laugh at the end of the
[__] story though there is no story
it's just
I'm going to tell you what
happened girl that I was dating the girl
I was dating white girl had a friend she
was cute yeah Jennifer you remember and
then she was and she had a coworker that
was actually going to that school and he
was in a frat white boy all white guys
and he goes I'll rent it out what's the
big deal and he signed the waiver he
signed the waiver and the only people
that came to that show and I even went
back to the Filipino Student Association
and I said hey I got someone to rent it
for us can you at least come and support
and they still didn't support they still
didn't come and no one came I put flyers
all over the school and uh the only
people that came was that that
fraternity and they brought their
sorority you remember that and there was
like maybe 15 20 people there my dad
came and anything but that's the grind
though and I and I was still able to pay
you because I went to all these local
businesses and I made a program and I
made sponsors and that's how I was able
to pay you so I didn't I didn't care I
didn't care that it was empty I was
happy that we were on stage Vegas is
that the end of the story and then I had
to I had I had to clean Chek fre Roy's
[__] is that what you
I have clean laugh at dude do you still
have that um shabo shaboo restaurant yes
where is that in Vegas it's in Vegas and
you're more than welcome is it good we
love Shabu chabu is it good yes it's
amazing Bobby yeah what do you have
sliced dog meat what's in there oh
that's fun is it good are you going for
the easy you co what you're doing you
have coob uh Kobe yeah you have coob
meat in there yes I have that's that's
generic that's nothing compared to what
I have oh really what do you have I have
wagu oh you have wagu yeah thank you
sorry yeah I have Mammoth meat on mine
where's your restaurant right where's
your restaurant it's in [__] Beverly
Hills right now dude damn Mammoth meat
and can you find Mammoth bro no I have
it that's that's a hard thing to $10,000
a slice a
slice yeah that must melt in your mouth
so good dude I got [__] polar bear
[__] have youever had po polar bear
[__] I've heard so good I've heard it's
good so good cold but
hot yeah yeah it's cold at the [__]
clip part is it a classy place your
restaurant yeah it's classy what what do
you mean it's it's clean it's clean
you're you're an investor you're an
investor in it yeah big time is it off
of the strip or where is it the what's
it called let's promote it what what's
it called it's called joo's place is no
oh God no be real is that what it's
called it's called YJ YJ yeah oh that's
cool yeah that's awesome so it's it's
off the strip it's right by my mom's
place she lives out like out in
Summerland did she work there a nice
area my mom works there she really she
helps out well she slices meat oh that's
amazing that's cool and then I tell her
to leave when the the meats we have
enough stocked you can go home so this
is a family run establishment then my
mom does not work there dip [__] no why
would I why would I have my mom slicing
meat at the age of 71 you [__] dick
she's retired okay she walks in like
godam M Marcos and ask free food that's
what she does when her son uh uh so
sorry so sorry U I'm going to stand up
again yeah take a stand that up right
take a stand take a knee takee you
[__] [__] let me say something
to you right now okay yes you fake tooth
[__] Okay F that's what you are
I know I know I am I want to tell you
something right now right there's a
place called um what's the shaboo shaboo
house in Little Tokyo it's the most
successful [__] shaboo place in La
and the parents work there right the guy
that owns it works slices the meat that
yes because he doesn't trust anybody
yeah but I'm just saying when you said
it I'm like like okay I could believe
that you [__] no no no there's a
difference between that family and mine
you want to know the difference yeah
that guy has to [__] work there
that's his paycheck whoa my mom's
retired you [__] F you let me say
this hey Mom thanks for giving birth to
me and you know what on your 70th
birthday you're hired go [__] slice
meat I wish you know what I wish upon
you now you know what I wish upon you
only one week at these comedy clubs
okay all right no I want you to be
successful I want you to be Su I'm you
really are nice I've always loved you
yeah we've always had a a banter we've
never had a we don't have a banter no
like a good banter together yes we
always have good banter I'm telling you
I'm telling you that when you yelled at
me in the parking lot bro I you need to
hear that I what did I say I don't
remember you said oh you you a bad
you you I accent always chat hard
TR
tiger people
like you you're a great you're spaghetti
bologan I mean everyone can cook
spaghetti don't don't don't pretty good
you guys [__] pretty good in fact do
you put carrots in it no I don't saus
yeah I put carrots in one you do yeah is
it good that way you're supposed to I
put car it down you supposed to yeah car
how do you just as a base you mean like
a Mir wait how do you stew down carrots
you stew it down with celery and onion
to make a miraa but how do you what's I
don't know what miraa is is that in
Harry Potter it's a dance
group hey everyone we're
Mira we're all
Filipino do you does that mean they boil
it they just stew it down to create like
aase yeah you boil why don't you do that
[__] I do it I not with a I can't get I
can't get no Maron on my [__] B noise
but with other stuff I do you can't [__]
put carrots in my [__] or what I do with
other stuff when I make you other stuff
like lat and all that stuff El you make
what else do you make um I make a lot of
stuff for myself cuz I cook a lot of
Filipino dishes and he doesn't really he
doesn't like Filipino he doesn't like
good cooking um he doesn't like yeah
like I don't know what it is I cook with
a lot of vinegar all the time so oh yeah
maybe he's not into it maybe you should
cook him some like real down home
Filipino stuff cetta yeah like I would
love to
makea I've
had all right it's all right you're so
angry I'm not angry so angry let me say
something right now you're so angry that
you have one
taste it's like booogy and then it's
like without bone or with bone in a pot
on fire it's like let me say something
right now let me say something to you no
no I'm tired of you [__] on my I'm
tired of you no I'm tired of you I'm
tired of you accusing me of not having
taste I have a plethora
I have a plethora of taste tell me
what's your favorite
pizza let's be real that's the taste of
13-year-old
child [__] it man real I like [__] [__]
you man [__] you coming
from Blue Apron Blue Apron has taste bu
let me say something okay um I I it's
not Japanese budget that's a budget yeah
if there's Japanese food I can do
Chinese food you grew up with Chinese
food right everyone Korean I was forced
to eat because of my parents I no one
ever cooked me Philipino food so in my
later days as an adult it's still
foreign to me the flavors although we go
to that barbecue place oh he had his
birthday at the Filipino at
par sort of like a barbecue Fusion it's
more Fusion it's delicious cornbread the
CH the
cornbread and just the corn thing that
they have there is [__] delici
their version of ele is really good too
you know I um I'm slowly you know I'm
slowly trying to get into Vietnamese
[__] I didn't like them at first because
you know you didn't like them who the
ones oh the food okay okay the man that
sounds I love the people I'm slowly
getting into Vietnamese but I didn't
really like them at first the food I as
a people no I love the people the food
yeah yeah the food I love the people are
you kidding me of course you love the
people I love the people you kidding me
yeah they tried to take you out though
didn't they they try to take me out yeah
did they oh when you were in uh no I
said no I said um he always uses the
word jungle Asian they try to take him
down I called vietnames jungle Asians
and then next thing I know I had to go
to like news Vietnamese News and really
news Outlet like I was like in doing
their news I'm so sorry we're all human
being you know doing that whole thing so
now he just calls philippinos jungle
Asians but then the Filipinos don't care
yeah yeah because he's also half white
no I mean you call Gilbert what does
that mean why do you what are you trying
to do with that because I I'll tell you
why I'll tell you why yeah why it's like
when Rob Schneider says you know what I
mean he's a full Asian you're not full
Asian who's not a full Asian Rob
Schneider yeah he's half he's a quarter
so are you yeah so am I and so is this
one but I'm not any less Filipino
because that's what I subscribe to
you're not less Philip Filipino you're
less Philip you're more Filipino than
him look we you your lady and I are more
Asian than you mhm I think so like the
whole Korean and you is less Asian than
half of us if that makes any sense
yeah maybe you're right I'm just being
I'm being real you are you're the
whitest Korean guy I
know that's real accusation no it's not
it's not the whest Korean man I've ever
met I grew up in Green Valley you're a
banana all right and in Green Valley in
powerway where I grew up was all white
people oh sorry all white people and we
had a tennis everything it was nice I I
had a country club a tutor you had a
tutor yeah and I I hey Toby you know
what me Toby like hey buddy you know
what I mean and then I would play hey
Bobby are you going to play tennis today
and I be yeah Parker I'll meet you out
there you know what I mean killer
yeah and so I grew up with that life
okay but let me say something right now
in my early 20s and as I got you know I
started trying to [__] goop girls all
right see you're going to get in trouble
for that Asians yeah no
that's not what you said that's how
you're trying to lose
sponsors they love that they love Blue
Apron next me it they love it with the
go flavor speaking of go try our new
Asian
Cuisine but I was at work today and some
guy came up to me and said George has a
pink dick yeah wow who's are you George
yeah I can see that though that's not
even funny to me his face is
pink so someone at work yeah listens to
Tiger belly yeah but he was like a high
up guy yeah so we got to be careful
there everywh there moles everywhere but
he goes George is a pink tick and I go
holy F might want to take back the go
flavor stuff yeah I take back go [__]
all that stuff added that yeah don't
bleep it but you know me retract we
retract I retract everything I've said
today yeah yeah yeah everything I've
ever said today hey should we start the
show over no I think this is great this
is how this is how I always do it yeah
yeah this is amazing
let's do truth talk you like truth talks
oh come on man gave you I just gave you
let's do another come on pain medication
I got goddamn stitches know I can't
really get into a physical [__]
banter with you I'm not doing physical
I'm doing truth I can't believe you're
here yeah but that's because I love this
guy no I said you want to cancel and
you're like no right if I had a deadly
poison in my dick okay I'm in
Uganda right I'm going hey he guys I'm
going to take a leak in the desert yeah
what you do you pull over right so I go
into the desert right pull my little
dick out right and all a sudden I you
know what I mean some something I go
what is that right I turn around and
it's like a mambo like one of those
black Mambo mamb Mambo whatever those
are right and he goes what's up he goes
what's up I go and he bites my dick
right and I have a poison on my dick and
you're the only one with me would you
suck the poison out of my dick
yes yes thank you just look up what do
you mean like don't look at me when I'm
doing
[Laughter]
that's the only way Bobby does it though
that's the only way oh right right right
look up right but that's not what I
would be doing here are the things that
I have to do I've had my dick you want
eye to eye I've had my dick right bit by
before and somebody sucked it out so
what I need to do is I need to grab the
back of your head right because I need
you I need all the poison St out so I
just need to control it a bit right I
need to look down because a bite mark is
kind of like a scratch Mark like when
you ask someone to scratch they don't
know exactly where they're just randomly
so you have to guide the hand you don't
know where the poison they don't know
where the poison is that's exactly what
I'm the poison and I also need to lock
eyes with you you have to look up and I
have to look down and I have to give you
a
wink I
do I'll get the poison out oh thank you
I know you would like you you do like to
say what's on your mind you do don't
[__] give me that look [__]
there's a bunch of words you said before
this [__] show
started edit yep yeah we do don't we do
we
do we not have to edit a bunch of words
okay I want to say this okay do we not
have to edit a bunch of words before you
want to talk about you want to talk
about [__] that was said before we even
started this thing I will tell you
something right now I know but I'm going
to tell you something right now dude all
right I say [__] up things like that
so I don't say it on the podcast so I
can just get it out okay Purge it I'm
purging it all right got it God all
right God
man yeah people are camera is that my
camera yeah
yeah like you know like people are
getting like I I'll be on stage and I'll
go um hey what are you like guy in front
they go I'm Filipino I go yeah you're
Asian then no I'm Filipino I'm a Pacific
island we're different are yeah so
people want to like now change the rules
right and the rules is this
okay if you have I don't know what the
rules are actually I don't know the
rules it's very easy the Philipp sits
the Philippines sits 2 hours away from
Japan there we go Japan's in the heart
of Asia which means you're [__] Asian
you're in Asia it's the reason it's
called southeast Asia because it's Asia
what I wanted that's the information I
want you need just because there's like
cross culture stuff happening doesn't
mean that geographically we're not a
part of Asia because we are right and if
I say we the Asians at and you're Indian
and you don't raise your hand or any or
make a sound you go [__] yourself
because hey Indians you're Asia too yeah
you are and you know what there's some
Russians that look Asian hell yeah that
their country goes into China yeah
they're I saw I saw a Russian fighter
and I swear to God at the end of the
fight I was I didn't know who he was I
know and I was like is this a Chinese
fighter right he had very pale skin his
eyes were very alond I was like and then
they were like he's from blah blah blah
GL CL
yeah love that City for a second there I
thought that was an Asian man to me like
when um borak came out I Googled what
people from Kazakhstan looked like
Kazakhstan so asan that's what it was it
was Kazakhstan mhm is that a real thing
why didn't you say that earlier no is it
I think that's where the I think that's
where the fire fighter was from yeah
they all look right kind of Chinese yes
it's crazy yeah it's crazy man yeah and
they all look like you know like if you
look at people from the border of China
and Russia like if people that live in
those like little towns they all look
like bork yeah you're not wrong but they
kind of do so right yeah I was actually
going to say that they have that's where
B Bor from that EUR asan yeah or Rob
Schneider like bork Rob Schneider does
not look Russian Rob or bork but even in
the Philippines how the [__] do you get
I'm sorry go
ahead what an [__] that was weird
yeah that was weider's likeo I'm kidding
I was just throwing it out I don't know
why you know here's the thing guys um I
say things that aren't necessarily funny
or not necessarily um relevant or it
might even have anything to do with what
we're talking about but um I throw it
out there it pops in my head I don't
have a filter I just say it and I'll cut
that part out Rob Schneider Not Mark
itk Mark Mark thek rub shter he's going
to do our podcast soon
okay you know your hair is ridiculous
the line I'm bald y it's not there is no
hair I know it's ridiculous if you grew
it out it would look ridiculous did you
just say it's a
ridiculous did you just say it's a
ridiculous it's a ridiculous it's hey
I'm Bobby Lee and welcome to it's a
ridiculous and that's the show show show
our show doent that our show it's a
ridiculous I'll mark it that's [__]
what was our show called at the time fun
fun show which is also a good funun show
fun fun fun show let's do this let's
make it's a ridiculous well let's no let
me say this you know let's get how prod
it maybe not because of ridiculousness
it can't happen fun fun is better Rob
deck show cuz Rob Dear has a
Ridiculousness oh that's right it's fine
but you know I was on a show got
cancelled you I was on a show for two
years what was the name of it spling up
to go okay and did you this going to
make me mad uh
oh did you not see me post a picture of
you congratulating you and telling
everybody to watch that show on my
Instagram I saw it and I thought I even
said oh Bobby that's so nice I liked it
actually you know what and who didn't
like it I'm G to tell you why nor nor
write a comment can I tell you why no
there's nothing you can tell me I can
tell you that no you can't tell me
you're to hear what said because you
scrolled past it that's the difference
between me and
you I appreciate your success and I want
nothing but the best for your
success I was and it is a ridiculous how
you're treating me I rolled it down I
was look rolling down Instagram I saw I
roll it down with my finger right I was
rolling it down with my finger and I saw
the post and there was my heart
fluttered but then there was another
thought that I had I don't know why I
had this thought but I thought it was a
trick of some sort what the [__] is
wrong with you did you not read the
caption I didn't read it why was it good
yeah it said everybody go watch my good
friend Bobby Lee new show you thank you
I'm seeing it live now thank
you is it too late I'm doing it l you're
lame I'm doing it in front of people
right now you're
lame that's that's what people that's
what what you're doing right there is a
lame act and you're
lame so my that's my mom's favorite word
you're a lame you're a l you're a lame
on our show what we do everything has
has to have an A in front of it yeah oh
nice you know my mom used to call me
you're a son of a
[__] she used to say that yeah yeah and
we would Snicker so loud and laugh to
ourselves but she was really mad heated
but she would go you're a son of a
[__] B is a son of a [__] and you're a
son of a [__] together both of your sons
of a [__] yeah does Filipinos have
phrases and we're like mom just called
herself a [__] yeah do you guys have
phrases in your language where if you
translate to English it's way more
disturbing yeah you're a son of a [__]
like uh yeah yeah my mom used to
say which means I'm GNA kill you and
throw you away whoa whoa but if you
translate it it's like there's two
things that are [__] bad I mean kill
me is one thing throw you away but to
throw me in a garbage dump yeah is crazy
and that's like an everyday thing people
say yeah yeah that that's like fighting
words that's like fighting words yeah no
I mean I don't know if it's fighting
where's my
pod like you wouldn't say that God damn
it hold on it's a train
wreck how we do it there there it is
yeah do it do it do do ridiculous
here there everywhere that would be our
show dude I know that's the opening
package right there bro can I say this
can I say this real quick how many times
have I asked Bobby to just come to a
show with me um multiple times multiple
like I'm not going to put you on the
card I'm not going to put you on the
poster I'm not going to even promote you
just come like like collabor like that's
how we collaborate and and blow up
together like I would love to share my
audience with you I even shared like a
huge venue with you one time I think it
was uh veas that's really interesting
that you say that I I swear to God am I
lying no you're not going to call me a
[__] liar do you have a podcast was
it at Treasure Island do you have a
podcast yes how many times have you done
tiger belly now this is your second time
right yeah how many times have I done
yours you you used to do
[__] [__] you man how long have you had
your podcast my camera yeah that's your
camera right there like no don't that's
my camera that's my camera how many
times have I asked you how many times
have I asked and what do you say what do
you say yes give no you don't no you
don't oh you [__] monkey what did he
you want to know he say you what he says
you want to know what he says yeah what
you want to know what he says what can
you start it at 9:00 in the evening and
I'll be there it's true yeah I go cuz my
pod starts at 11:00 he goes I don't wake
up he doesn't who does who 11:00 a.m.
the world Bobby yeah but not comedians
[__] not this one does yeah it's like a
vampire go hey we're having a party I go
where you at my house what time 2:00
p.m. when the sun's
out we're vampires do it again sell it
to the camera again do it again sell it
to the camera when the sun's
out we're
vampires you don't you people get up at
11 when they're like I'm on you know
people get up a Liv like I'm on that new
show called um uh teabag yeah HBO it's
grated high they get up they go to the
gym at 10:00 in the morning they go get
like a brunch or whatever Comics at
teabag I don't know yeah right and then
Comics 6:00 p.m. we kind of get up drink
our little coffee we go to do a show
that's what a real comic does anyway um
you can get up at 11 p.m. all a.m. all
you want but papa is not going to do
that Papa's going to remain a a comedian
do you sleep at reasonable hours yeah
what time bit at like uh 4:00 in the
morning me too I feel like that's
reasonable for a comic yeah that's
reasonable for a comic I'm always you
know writing